نحن طاوله الزهر بلبنان عادت الى الواجهه
ولم تعد حكرا على على كبار السن الى جانب
وهو الجيل الثالث من عائله اشتهرت بصناعه
هذه الطاولات الى ان اليه ادخل عليها لمسه
عصريه خبرنا اكثر الي اليوم هيدا القطعه
التقليديه صارت اكثر فيها لمسه حديثه
بفضلك صباح الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم
طاوله الظهر طبعا بعد ما عملت
تاريخها بالعالم رياضه
ذهنيه حلوه كثير
وغير غير الوضع اللي وصلنا له اليوم على
السوشيال ميديا وكلنا ابديت بدنا تحدي
ملموس بين شخصين كتير عنيت الظهر
بصناعتها وكثير وصلت لناس وعم تعطي حافز
كثير كبير للجيل القديم او الجديد بس يكون
اسمه عم سوسه بقسمه للشخص عم تعطيه حافز
لحتى يربح لحتى يحافظ عليها اكثر
ابديه كمان منه من حفتنا يعني اليوم انت
هيدي الحرفه بحد ذاتها كيف طورتها شو
ادخلت عليها تحديثات هي حرفه تطعيم وتوسيع
الخشب حرفه بيو جدي اللي تعلمتها منه هون
من انا وصغير
كلها مبنيه على الفورماتيك كلها بتصنع
يدويا لينحط الاشكال حتبادها
دورت انا لقيت انه في تطوير لتطعيم الخشب
اللي هو بنقدر نستخرج منه نوع من منه
اسامي عملت هذا المزيج بين الحرفه العمرها
100 سنين وبين تطور الصناعي لصرت اخذ
الاسم من الخشب الطبيعي وعامل اشكال
الهندسيه جديده قادر تكمل اللي كان ناقص
بهالحرفه
بيجتمع فيها رموز الحياه للعبه طاوله
الظهر ويعود تاريخها
ل 2800 عام قبل الميلاد
انوجدت اقدم طاوله بمدينه
النهرين اذا منلاحظ على عدد
الفلاشات اللي بينلعب عليهم الاسهم لعبه
24 ساعه بالنهار 24 ساعه باليوم 12 ليل 12
النهار 30 حجر هن عدد ايام الشهر على طول
على الزهر من الارقام من واحد لسته ليكون
المجموع تبعهم على طول سبعه يعني
واحد على طول المجموع سبعه ايام بالاسبوع
فيها فصل اثنين ثلاثه طول السنه اذا اعمل
برمه لعبه الطاوله 15 حجر اللي بيكونوا
لكل لعيب بس ينضرب 24 طلعنا ب 360 يوم
بالسنه الكل ما بنعرف انه 2800 عام قبل
الميلاد ما كان في بوصله ما كان في ساعه
كيف هالمخترع العاب قدر يعرف هذه الرموز
كلها بهداك الوقت
انت تحضر لادخالك نعم باذن الله عم يشتغل
عليه تقريبا اكثر من سنه ووصلنا تقريبا
لاخره تقريبا ان شاء الله راح يكون في
ايفنت وراح يكون في
مفاجاه كمان عدم موضوع باذن الله الدخول
هالطاوله لا موسوعه اكبر طاولتك وصلوا
لعدد كبير من المشاهير من الفنانين ورؤساء
جمهوريه
وكبار ايضا حدثني
الموضوع بشرفني وبيقبل كثير من الحرفه
اللي عم بعملها وعم بخليه يعني يدخل عبر
التاريخ اذا بدك اكثر
كونها هاي اللعبه كانت لعبه الامبرور
الامبرورز وكبار الملوك والرؤساء ومن اول
مسيره هوليود كانت لعبه الفنانين وكبار
المخرجين وكبار وصلت لكثير من الفنانين
اللبنانيين وعرب وعالميين ابرزهم الله
يطول بعمره سلطان جورج وسوف
اللبنانيه
راغب علامه نجوى كرم احلام حفظ الالاب
طبعا للجميع
عرب احلام
يعني كاظم الساهر ولا على طول اذا بذكر
اسامي يمكن بنسى السيده المجد الرومي
عصير الحلاني على
وقتنا انتهى بس انا رح ساعد اليه واقول
لكم كمان انه وصل ل 11 رئيس جمهوريه
بيناتهم ماكرون
وصل لرونالدينيو
لفقه كبيره من الفنانين العرب والاجانب
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر على هذه المقابله
وشكرا لكم عن بيروت بين جواي